let's meet the cast with my lightning
resolved quickly
Adams you know the girls throw eggs at
you and marbled painful she'll go one
[Applause]
way girlfriends be there Jane Lima heal
and Maura broth a quinoa and you're
going to go in jump here's our viewer
blank like a CREP
[Applause]
so we will get right to it by my count
I've got all my memories made but it is
in a minutes as we have seen a primetime
Network TV show feature of black super
Newton so I wanted to add copper to smog
reviews especially wide black lightning
and what does it mean to bring a
character of color to the superhero TV
world that we have now Wow I start you
out the easy questions why black light
because I think it's time I think
Jefferson cares is the epitome of what
black men are he is a man that is in
love with his wife he loves his children
he loved his community
so these you know this family is likely
to the Obamas of the superhero I think I
think I think the thing that makes it so
timely is that you know we look on the
news and we see that there's 125
shootings in Chicago over a fourth of
July weekend there are no superheroes
going in that neighborhood trying to
save people a black life is going to go
to that so I think that's why we need
tell us what it's like to play a
character like Jetson peers who is
operating in a world you know we're used
to seeing these superheroes at 30,000
feet know saving the world but this is a
cat who's trying to save his
neighborhood right exactly
I mean it's phenomenal I mean he you
know like Celine said you know he's
going into the community and I think
that we we affect change
positively kind of from the N word out
so he starts on family to his community
and then
that's outward usually we see heroes who
are just trying to save the world but he
trying to save the world one person at a
time now before we go too far we have
promised some special news some a
revelation about the cast so Saleem can
you tell us who's doing in the cast that
folks are just going to find out here
and comedy oh you guys no no you guys
know the character of Gambia right well
we got James remar to play that car
could you guys know we're in class now
what do you have remember the character
and secretary and from the comic
inspector Henderson is going to be Damon
Gupta who is amazing just an amazing
actor so we're super excited about
bringing them along the next
announcements are going to be even more
exciting so it's just getting better and
better
now that's the way we do like like
chocolate no pun intended
okay now it's interesting to me because
the comic book movie and TV world have
taken a lot of flack for not being
diverse and some of us have been crying
out for a while to see something like
this a TV show that centered on black
clothes so can you talk a little bit
about the responsibility of doing that
and what can you bring to the screen
that maybe we wouldn't see or we haven't
seen in these characters that that
aren't people covered I think it's a
celebration a of our culture that is a
part of being an American that through
our lens through our scope through our
pain and joy struggle triumph we can see
that we really are all connected I think
it but it's through that celebration of
specific of who we are to connect to the
universal of who we are
I also think that we bring up our
grandpa you're going to say the
moderator is very handsome person and I
just want to speak wrestling a little
bit about the diversity and I think you
know yes of course we are a black
families but I do think our stories and
what we're going to talk about more in a
explore transcend that and I think it's
just beyond color I think it's great
that we're there but I think it's
actually besides the fact that we're
black and I think it's more about
universal things that we're all going to
relate to we're all going to connect
with that that's what I'm hoping I mean
it doesn't dare
it's come back right over I think but I
have black lightning and eventually
thunder and lightning helping to save
the community we get to shade in the
humanity of those who need that help in
our communities and we also get to
stayed in the reason why some of our bad
guys are bad it's not that they it's
like a choice we all have a choice we
can use our power for good or we can use
our power for bad and some of its
circumstantial what's happening in our
neighborhoods
I think it gives that's an opportunity
and that's that responsibility that we
can add from our perspective of what's
happening in our world real world today
and maybe inspire change within the
viewer then connect oh yeah that's
interesting but when I see TV shows
Network TV shows try to tackle a crime
for example they're afraid to show black
criminals but when you look at the south
side of Chicago and the gang violence
you know it involves my community and so
how do can you show those problems if
you don't show who is suffering and
who's also a part of it and what's so
interesting about being Mary Jane and
girlfriends you guys have really
captured black culture right but now you
got a superhero show yes so in what tell
me about the challenge of doing that I
mean we know you got like culture but
now you got to do the severely - the
biggest challenge was accepting that
this black man was running around town
and that's the easiest way to get shot
by to be the weird car running around
are you saying Black Lightning lives
matter
I have got roundel I think I think for
us you know we have been so character
based and we will continue to be
character based I think it is about
balancing out when this man uses his
powers how he uses his powers and one I
think that those are that was the
toughest thing because we really want
people to get to know this family and
their powers like their race is just a
part of who they are like the most
interesting thing about this family is
not that they're ever in America you
know I don't walk around thinking oh I'm
walking around I'm sexy on my African
American you know I walk around just
thinking him I got to pay these bills
and I got to get the job done right but
I think that the challenge is not giving
into the idea that we need to be perfect
and to your point about exhibiting the
problems of these communities in truth
yes there is definitely a problem with
police brutality and we will get into
that but there is also a huge problem
with us killing each other and we don't
mind addressing I'd like to guys could
tell the crowd about your characters too
you talk a little bit about who you
playing and how you're approaching the
role hi so I play and dissapears the
older daughter of Jefferson and Lynn and
then she said very powerful in her own
right and she does aspire to follow in
her father's footsteps but again she she
wants her own path and she wants to do
in her own way and she's just a force
she's fearless she knows who is she
wants she's ready to fight for the
injustice that's going on within the
community she's also protective over as
a sister and you know it's just a part
of that family that you think that we
have yes and I play Jennifer peers with
the youngest daughter of Jefferson
Pierce
like lightning and I love the fact that
at the start it just starts off with her
being a teenager and struggling with
that she doesn't have superpowers yet
she's just struggling with finding
herself and that's where she is at the
start and then you see her develop
superpowers and where that takes her
character and the character arc that she
has to go through and it's very very
complex and very interesting for both of
our characters pieces yeah and I played
in his ex-wife of black lightning mother
to these two incredible sources I don't
have superpowers in the traditional
sense apart from love and kindness and
we can fabulous well thank you and yet
in in in a way I'm kind of the glue that
holds the fans together and keeps them
grounded and I'm sure we'll have to
navigate is really complicated terrain
of having young women going out into the
world you know trying to shape summer
mold them with this extra layer of
having these powers and and how they
have a nurture and have a cultivated if
I can understand think was exciting me
is that the superhero
we always need support and so yes the
struggle between and certainly black
lightnings character is accepting one's
power but who was the support underneath
it he's got these two daughters that are
funded lineage from his blood who embody
and then and exhibit their own power and
so and this one is going to be Thunder
and his daughter Jennifer is going to be
lightning and as Christine talked about
the glue for Lynn sometimes our role and
that one thing that we can all think
about is how are we supporting and for
the power supporting each other in the
through love and so I've been really
very excited about the development of
those characters
my question is for Christ Hydra
superhero I just wanted to say I just
wanted to ask what was the most scary
like stun
as a superhero you had to be be due and
when we watch the most well it's
actually kind of a thing and think that
the most again cake was I was on a wire
up on this building and had to just step
off the building he's not jump off the
building I would like blue cool stepping
off the building like that's enough
occur oh and Phil additionally having
that did you got to get used to you know
an ATAR july gonna look cool doing but
oh oh by the individual book like a rod
like white even once I got used to it
was just like yeah do that again let's
do it again let's go oh yeah that wasn't
so what he's saying it's right more
scenes where he has to jump off the
building no step off I wait why that's
what I want to do what comply oh that's
okay I think hold we don't have time to
take it off I see that we have a minute
here I'm a common ask one more question
anything there are a lot of great black
superheroes in the DC Universe was there
a particular reason why Black Lightning
was the one that make sense to make it
to a series right now yeah just the
grounded in the character of Jefferson
it touched on so many things that were
interesting to me again a father I'm a
father he had two wife I have a wife he
grew up in an area that was dangerous so
did I so I just identified so much with
the character that it makes sense for me
what I think you know one of the most
popular albums right now is jay-z's
album and I think the reason people
really like that albumen is because it
comes from an authentic black male voice
and it's describing what he feels like
as a man a father and an artist I think
the thing that is going to make this so
much fun for myself and the other
writers is that
this is going to come from an authentic
black male voice and there's no filter
and I'm not afraid to talk about the
things that we need to talk about I
think that's what will set this show
apart from any other I love all of the
other shows and if they have paved a way
for this show but I think this character
is going to add something to the
conversation we're able to give
something back to the culture and when I
say called tracking black culture but
also I like black people to Dan
muffler's but I also think we're going
to be giving something back to the
Comerica culture when I was a kid
growing up I dressed up like Batman
Batman doesn't look like me but I
accepted him because he was a hero what
I expect by this time next year but I
expect by the time we get to Halloween
what I love is the idea that I will be
able along with all of these amazing
artists is to see little black boys and
little black girls have a choice they
can either be black Batman or they can
be black like they can be Supergirl or
they can be thunder or like to me that
is what this is all about giving
opportunity for other
and I want to thank you for landing if
you give me an option from cons lately
on Nick Fury so thank you
you